[Music]
thank you
hey everybody happy Sunday what's going
on yep we're talking about some cartoons
[__] yeah The Hobbit
this one right here man
I saw it when I was a little kid on
television I did too I loved it and then
a couple years later they came out with
like they showed the other two on
television although those were not
related to this one it was a different
um
yeah yeah but I loved them you know this
was this first one I saw on television I
was just like enamored with it and then
later on a few years later when I was
old enough to be in Middle School
[__] Dungeons and Dragons came out so
it made a lot of sense you know Dungeons
and Dragons made perfect sense to me
after seeing this
um
so we saw it again
just uh last night yeah I noticed that
uh HBO Max had added it yeah and I was
like all excited because I had I saw it
a million times when I was a kid a
million [__] times yeah and but I
hadn't seen it for a long time but the
weird thing is that when we were
watching it again last night I
remembered every line of dialogue every
like inflection really of a yeah I
remembered every single thing so I must
have seen it like a million it must like
have been just imprinted in my brain
like I had only seen it once yes I saw
it once on broadcast television
so that was 1977 probably yeah I mean
unless they re-ran it I don't know if
they did and uh never saw it again up
until now I remembered a lot of it
seeing it again a couple things
a couple things I didn't remember
correctly
as a kid
first of all it's animated a lot better
than I remembered it it looks a lot
better and it's actually beautiful it
looks really nice it may have something
to do with uh
CRT television and HD when you when they
showed this on broadcast television it
looked kind of crappy from how I
remembered it
um but if you see it on HD on a modern
screen
through you know an HD stream it looks
good real good it has a very painterly
quality to it I really like uh the
backgrounds because they almost kind of
look like watercolor like muted
watercolors it's really nice another
thing that [__] me up is that as a kid
I thought that this was like an Epic
Movie
that took [__] all day to watch oh
man just a lot of stuff happens yeah
it's just like an hour long
when you're a kid you think that you've
[__] been taken all the way around
the world to the we've been on a journey
back and you're like oh no man I made it
no this [__] goes really fast it's very
Abridged uh you know I mean all the main
[__] is in there from the novel because
they were very um you know they were
adamant that I was like well we we want
pretty much everything that happened in
the novel to happen the thing and they
didn't want to add anything so like all
the major events happen but because it's
only 80 minutes and because this was
geared more towards like a family
audience or kids yeah then some of the
stuff had to be like truncated like so
some stuff like doesn't take as long I
think there was only one major event
like that man bear guy that they yeah
took that out but other than that I
think everything else was in there
another thing about it that I remembered
wrong is that uh I remember this thing
being pretty [__] adult pretty
vicious there's no violence in it not
really kind of like yeah I mean people
get killed and die and stuff but they
don't show it stylistically yeah it's
not like super it's not bloody yeah uh
when uh Bilbo stabs a a spot a giant
spider it's a giant talking spider or
any kind of like a goblin
they don't actually show him stab
anything and then they just show the Gob
of spinning and getting smaller and
going away like it's going into another
universe or something they don't
actually show anybody killing anybody
else now towards the end when they were
fighting smog the dragon they showed
that they showed smog getting hit with
arrows
um I guess because it's not a human
figure I was gonna say he's a dragon
he's a dragon so you can do that
but I don't know why they didn't worry
about it because that spider wasn't a
human figure that's true it didn't you
know
it's just it was just kind of like the
censorship of the day
but I didn't notice it as a kid as an
adult you notice it versus you know more
modern anime
still all in all this is a classic flick
man I've it's up there with like
Watership Down if you've ever seen
Watership Down that's another good one
that one that one holds up
um it's like that although I think I
kind of say that I think I give it to
Watership Down
well yeah I mean Watership Down is more
adult or adult vile you know kind of
violent and stuff like that this one you
know you can tell it was made for kids
but it's still even though it's not
violent they don't really show people
get like legit getting stabbed or
anything like that but I will say that
like the character does not like the
goblins and the trolls and stuff like
that they're scary so they weren't in
the spiders and they you know so they
weren't like scared to make it scary
yeah but they just didn't want to make
it like bloody or gory necessary great
little songs they're kind of like on par
with like the the haunted mansion from
Disneyland you know going down a troll
town and all kind of weird [__]
yeah yeah that's the best song of the
movie yeah now the songs were mostly
taken from the book other than the kind
of folky one at the beginning which was
like the theme song Like The Greatest
Adventure song which every time I watch
this movie that [__] gets stuck
in my head for real but um so it's been
stuck in my head like all day today like
singing that but that was the only thing
that was written specifically for for
this like all the other ones were I mean
obviously they they had to be adapted
like had music added to them but they
the lyrics to them were in the book yeah
you know what I mean yeah the book had
little songs and poems and [__] in it I
read the book when I was a kid yeah it's
a great book you know but this is a good
introduction to this material just if
you know if you're a kid or if you even
if you don't want to read the book you
just want to see kind of what Lord of
the Rings was like you can either watch
this or you can [__] listen to a Led
Zeppelin album
yeah this is honestly this is good this
is a good way to introduce kids to
Tolkien I think because I feel like this
well this is what got me into because
I'm not super into like you know Tolkien
or anything like that but this
definitely got me interested in that and
interested enough that I read the novel
because I saw this first before I read
it you know what I mean yeah this is
kind I will say that it's kind of like
you know it's like the cliffs notes
version yeah the sparks notes or
whatever they're calling it nowadays so
it's like I said it's very abbreviated
and like stuff happens like really
quickly you know and there's not a huge
amount of like character development and
stuff because they had to cram a lot of
events into the movie
but it's a good like I said it's a good
kind of like basic breakdown if it has
all this stuff in there it's not like
because I'm gonna say I didn't love the
three-part uh you know Peter Jackson
Hobbit I just thought it was so okay it
was all right yeah but I mean it just
seemed like it better yeah it just
seemed like that it's it's almost kind
of like that one was like too much that
was like too overstuffed like it didn't
need to be that long whereas this one
was maybe slightly Too Short maybe it
could have gone on them for a little bit
more and it you know it had to leave
some stuff out or leave like a lot of
the depth of the novel out but it was
still like a good just breakdown it's
just a good Adventure the one I Remember
Loving was the rotoscope version of Lord
of The Lord of the Rings
remember that yeah it was kind of like
fire and ice
yeah that was um that was about Frodo
and he meet he meets
um uh what's his name he meets uh Gollum
uh then they got
like a human Warrior and a damn dwarf
who's like a viking and they gotta
they're forced to run with the with the
orc Army to this place and that was
[__] great man I haven't seen that in
a long time I want to see that one again
Lord of the Rings that was what
1979-78 yeah it was a couple years after
this because well that's the thing and I
feel like and I think too that like
later on
um they released uh this movie The Lord
of the Rings which I think was uh Ralph
bakshi and also the Return of the King
of like the animated Return of the King
like they put them all out as if they
were all like the same production kind
of but they weren't this one was
actually Rankin bass
um you know who were famous for doing
the the stop-motion stuff like Rudolph
the Red-Nosed Reindeer and
uh you know the Year Without a Santa
Claus with the Heat Miser and all that
um and they also did Frosty the Snowman
and they did The Last Unicorn which I
kind of want to get into uh doing that
once like reviewing that at some point
too because that was good but yeah this
that was them but the thing about it and
rank and bass they did this a lot
actually and I think they they did this
with their stop-motion too it's like
they did all the storyboarding and the
scripting and stuff like that like in
the United States but they would usually
I don't necessarily want to say farm out
but they would usually work with like a
Japanese uh company to like actually do
the stop-motion animation and they did
the same thing here matter of fact they
worked with a a studio in Japan called
top craft most of the animators of whom
went on to become Studio Ghibli Ghibli
you know that really famous like uh
animates yeah yeah so they went on to do
that but that so this was like an early
uh thing of them so they were the ones
that did the actual animation although I
think all the character development and
scripting and stuff was done over here
but I had totally forgotten I think that
I had confused because like I said the
the animated Lord of the Rings The
Return of the King I think were like a
different production company so I always
kind of like lumped them all together
but they're not this one is Rank and
bass the others who are not right so and
this one came out first because you have
to think when this came out these guys
did all three now in another format but
I remember Return of the King and I
thought Return of the King was the same
as the same guys who did The Hobbit and
I thought that they did a middle one too
but I didn't see that one I just thought
I'd missed it but it turned out no they
didn't know they just did they were all
Independents but they they're all
independent clicks but they did each
each book now well Rank and bass they
were going to do Lord of the Rings yeah
like but then like I guess they kind of
got snaked a little bit like so like
another production company when it came
in because at that point
um I think that the books were in the
public domain for a brief time I don't
know it was I think there was some kind
of like copyright thing about it so
there was in it so another like Studio
started developing and they're like well
[__] we can't do it now because you know
someone else is doing it the 14 year old
me said that they were all good I had
seen them all I knew the story by the
time I've seen them all but I have to I
you know the 50 year old something the
50-something year old me has to see him
again this one I give it a pass I think
it's good it was a good it was it was a
fun watch it's kind of a watch walk down
memory lane if you don't know these
stories this is a good introduction to
the stories yeah I really give it to the
animated Lord of the Rings based on
memory although I I remember really
liking that when I thought the tone was
really good from from what I remember it
kind of reminded me of Fire and Ice
which is another rotoscope type movie
with human actors that they damn they
kind of did Drew over them so it looked
really good that was kind of like a
Conan type story something out of like
heavy metal
um but I I really remember liking Lord
of the Rings I want to see that one next
well the thing about it like I have not
seen the animated Lord of the Rings or
The Animated Return of the King in a
very long time
um I remember when I was a kid I
remember liking this one much more but
maybe that's because I mean I like this
book much more yeah I know that's a
weird thing to say that might be a
controversial opinion but I actually
like The Hobbit book better than the
Lord of the Rings book I couldn't really
just super get into like Lord of the
Rings I remember like and Lord of the
Rings as a teenager you know like 13 14
around that time because it was darker
that movie was a darker movie and it had
more adult type delivery to the themes
that's the way I remembered I remember
thinking it was like
watching something out of a damn Heavy
Metal magazine if you guys know what
heavy metal was it was all [__] anime
basically that we had
and um I want to see it again but I
remember liking that one a lot better
well I'd have to see it again like I
said I remember when I was a kid liking
this one more than that one but I'd seen
this one a bunch more times so this one
kind of like imprinted itself on my
brain because like I said just watching
it again last night like I remembered
pretty much this one has a bunch of
songs and anything and everything I'll
give it that it's almost like a
semi-musical uh but the animated Lord of
the Rings didn't have that the animated
Lord of the Rings the tone was a lot
more like uh like the Sinbad series
Sinbad in the eye of the tiger and uh it
[__] Jason the Argonauts it was like
that that's the way I remembered it but
like I said I got to see it again it's
been a long time can we talk about how
[__] awesome Gollum is in this though
yeah he's good that's my favorite part
and that voice actor
that is uh brother Theodore who was I
mean he was kind of a performance artist
it was like in kind of a weirdo I
remembered him the first time I think I
actually saw his face was in The Burbs
he was one of the weird neighbors like
he was like the patriarch of like the
weird neighbor family in The Burbs that
was brother Theodore but he was the one
that did gollum's voice and I still I
think I like this Golem better than the
one in the live action movies I'm not
nothing against like Andy Circus because
he was like amazing but I don't know
this one he was just like so
creepy and it's just like I really
really loved the voice like the voice
performance was so good yeah I like the
voice performance in this one I didn't
really like how how he was drawn he's
drawn almost kind of like a big toad all
right I liked really the Golem from Lord
of the Rings based on memory the
animated Lord of the Rings
because he looked a little bit more like
a human and I remember his dialogue I
remember liking it a little bit better
he that he would do it and it's because
you don't you don't know it in The
Hobbit
but well I guess now they don't really
say so much in The Hobbit
you find out in Lord of the Rings the
gollum at one time was a Hobbit
yeah but they don't you don't know that
because Bilbo just falls in the [__]
hole and hears like this frog monster
coming at him yeah he he was a hobbit
that had been mutated by the evil Powers
the evil force of the of the Ring of the
one ring
which you find out later and Gandalf
tells you in this one yeah you just
think that's a ring but your descendants
will know a lot more about that ring
than you yeah winged that's that's
important [__] so uh that was like the
one ring to rule them all later on it
turns out he you know it's it's an evil
[__] artifact
uh that can control a bunch of other
evil artifacts and well I wouldn't say
they're evil they're just super powerful
evil things are after them but they were
evil too because the more you wore that
ring the more addicted you got to it
yeah because they collect corrupted it
it corrupted you yeah which you don't
really know like I said you know this
was the first Tolkien that I had ever
looked that I was ever exposed to I read
the book after I saw this because I saw
this I mean this came out on TV when I
was five but I think that I didn't see
it until later because I feel like it
was probably on cable a lot or they
reached it on TV so I probably saw it
when I was I don't know seven eight nine
years old something like that and I saw
it like a bunch of times and I think I
mean all the parts of this are great it
does when you watch it as an adult
like you said
um it does seem like shit's happening
like super super quick and it does seem
like things get resolved like really
easily or like really quickly you know
what I mean it's like you know oh they
got captured by the spiders and then you
know Bilbo comes in and he's like oh I
saved you and then they run away you
know what I mean but you can see why
they did that because they were trying
to keep it you know under 90 minutes and
it was for a kid's audience so they're
just kind of like trying to cover all
the stuff and I honestly with that
limitation I think they did a good job
because they did spend a lot of time
where they needed to spend time you know
what I mean they spent a lot of time
with uh Gollum because they knew that
that was like the best part so there was
kind of like a that whole like sequence
where they do the riddles and all that
other stuff and I like that they spend a
lot of time on that and you know they
they spent quite a bit of time like in
the forest with the spider and you know
doing some other things but yeah like
some stuff gets kind of short tripped
but that's okay you know what I mean and
I did like the whole thing with um that
whole sequence with Bilbo going in and
talking to well they they pronounce it
smog in this but I'm pretty sure that
it's supposed to be Smaug yeah I mean
that's what I have those exotic [__]
accents and [__]
I mean every other adaptation I've ever
said smog but they say Smog and they
called him a worm a worm yeah a lot but
that was another word for drag another
word for Dragon but you didn't know that
if you didn't know that you were a kid
worm is kind of like wyvern which also
means Dragon wyvern
yeah yeah
they're talking about
um
oh Oracle is mundane said this is still
the gollum voice I hear in my head even
though Andy Circus did a great job too
yeah me too and honestly we saw this me
and my brother saw this so many times
that we used to like quote the [__]
the gollum lines at each other all the
time all the time it's a fun little
flick it's just a little bit over an
hour
and it takes you all over the place and
there's little [__] songs and you get
to you get you you get the skeleton
basically
yeah yeah
and then they're [__] the Goblins the
Goblins you're welcome
and then they even they even kind of
[__]
they even kind of [__] like uh
force in Concepts like magical swords
that have names that are famous and [__]
even the lamb drink like Glam drink the
goblin cleaver or some [__] yeah
wouldn't that goblin cleaver yeah goblin
cleaver was one of them and and they
only get like two or three lines in the
whole movie but they're like oh man you
got that thing and you're like yeah okay
you have that thing and they only show
it a couple times but in the book that
[__] was more mystical and that that's
what kind of
that's what [__] created [__] [__]
like Dungeons and Dragons which in the
modern era ended up being video games
like Morrowind and all that well this
fantasy role-playing games
and some people a lot of people a lot of
y'all don't know y'all too [__] young
but you Old-Timers here listen [__]
Fallout is just a reboot of a game we
used to play called Gamma World all
right Gamma World where all that was was
just Dungeons and Dragons in a
post-apocalyptic world
that was in the future where you had
[__] lays you could find a laser gun
and machine guns and you could fight
mutated monsters and even find [__] like
flying saucers from other planets if you
know Gamma World that's all [__] fall
out of us but
um this is the [__] Tolkien in these
movies is where all that [__] came from
including actually Gamma World Gamma
World came from token I mean yeah it's
almost like a massively influential
uh Richard Frazier sent Leonard Nimoy
Bilbo Baggins mid-60s I've seen the
video yeah he played Bilbo head back no
you never heard that song no oh my God
you know you need to go you need to sing
a song about Bilbo Baggins yeah you did
it there that nah
you need to you need to [__] saying a
lot a lot of [__] hokey songs yeah
yeah yeah he did well yeah let's see
this guy with diamonds and [__] yeah
okay that's hilarious too yeah but Lucy
in the Sky with John
but Leonard Nimoy did too and he did a
song called I think it was called The
Ballad of Bilbo Baggins was that was
that what it's called yeah and it's like
yeah he did like a whole album so yeah
you need to go check that out it's funny
to be honest
um you know when the chat does it it's
funny but you kind of expect it to be
funny because it's William Shatner you
know what I mean but I kind of feel like
when Leonard Nimoy does it you're so
used to him being Spock yeah that it's
like when you see him doing this kind of
like hippy-dippy sort of like you know
he's all smiling and stuff and it's just
like it's way way funnier to me
I mean imagine you know Mirror Universe
Spock back there yeah singing like kind
of like a hippie folk song about about
little Bilbo I mean it's it's [__]
hysterical it's hysterical yeah band
knows Grandma world that's right man
yeah
and Oracle says uh this is also the
movie I think of when it comes to Bilbo
naming his sword sting yeah I mean even
when I was younger because I mean by the
time when I saw this like in the early
80s like you know I was really into the
police so it's like every time he named
his
he named his knife sting and I was just
kind of like I would always think of
like rocks it you know what I mean
I expected to like sink that like while
he was here and now you will too you're
welcome so you wanna uh you want to
review uh the animated Lord of the Rings
well eventually we can I just well like
I said we thought of doing this one
because
um I just noticed I was watching
something else on HBO Max and I just
noticed that it was on there and I was
like oh my God I haven't seen that in
forever and then I kind of watched the
first couple minutes and then you came
in and you were like hey I want to watch
that yeah and then I want to see Lord of
the Rings yeah now we can't review that
this week because we have to do so we're
doing this movie today because like I
said with everybody's voting you know on
the on the movies that we do so we're
doing this movie today and then Tuesday
we're doing the greasy Strangler
okay because tomorrow we're doing a
haunting yeah I mean
um Oracle says Tom and Jenny wanted to
say this before I forgot I have like a
phantom hair it's driving me crazy
um remember that series food that built
America there's a new season on Hulu
Okay I'm gonna have to watch that after
a haunting tonight because man I love
that [__] joke I finished watching
snack versus Chef last night that was
like I'm not gonna tell you guys who won
in case you want to watch it but uh that
was a fun show yeah uh sagicorn says up
in New York we said smog is the dragon's
name honestly I think I like smog better
I mean to me it always kind of looked
like Smog and I was like Smaug what the
[__] are you talking about get out of
here with that [__] but apparently like
according to Tolkien nerds that's how
you're supposed to pronounce it I guess
he's one of the best characters in the
movie
he has like some of the best lines
that was Richard Boone's voice like
somebody said earlier about
um how he was in like he did like a lot
of uh Rank and bass stuff like voice
acting for them I really liked I was
watching this other review of The Hobbit
and he was pointing out something that
was actually really cool because he was
a little bit comparing the voice acting
or like the way the characters were
portrayed in this you know adaptation as
opposed to like the big Peter Jackson
ones and he's like I think Benedict
Cumberbatch did did smog in the um in
the movies and he's like you know that
was cool and everything but he's like I
kind of like this one better because he
was almost like
not not like as overtly intimidating
because like when Bilbo first comes into
the treasure chamber and he can't see
him because he's like invisible he's all
just like yeah no you're in there you
know what I mean like he's not
worried about it or he's not trying to
be scary or anything like that which in
a way makes him more intimidating I
think that they didn't
some people wondered because I saw like
some different reviews of this but they
wondered why they had drawn smug to kind
of look like so like his face kind of
looks like a cat
it kind of looks like a Chinese dragon
like rather than yeah like rather than
like a traditional like European style
dragon or something like a Chinese
dragon and maybe they were kind of
speculating like well maybe it was just
like easier to animate the mouth like
for when it was talking or something
like that I'm not really sure why but it
did kind of look like that I like how
his eyes lit up I had forgotten about
that aspect yeah I'm like the eyes
lighting up I thought that was pretty
cool like headlights yeah like what yeah
but um one thing I remember from seeing
this as a kid I think and I had
forgotten how abrupt the beginning of
this is I mean it's literally like they
do The Greatest Adventure the little
folk song and everything and then Bilbo
is just in his little house mining his
own beeswax with his little furry feet
and whatnot yeah and then like but like
Gandalf pops out from behind the tree
he's like guess what you're going on an
adventure here's a bunch of [__]
dwarves and they're gonna come eat all
your [__] and like just like make
themselves at home in your house quickly
and I'm sitting there going
um quickly I don't know you people like
what are you why are you eating all my
food and drinking all my beer like what
like even when I was a little kid I was
like rude
but you know what I mean I think in the
book I haven't read the book in a long
time but in the book obviously I think
there was more of like a build up well
there's also a lot of poetry and there's
a lot of uh [__] descriptions of
other things that happened a long time
ago so there's a bunch of stuff that's
not totally relevant to the story just
like background stuff from what I
remember
so they cut all that out
and yeah so it's basically just like
Gandalf's like hey we got some dwarves
another thing come on in another
telling of the story
is that you realize how much that
Gandalf is nothing more than just a dose
ex machina I mean that's all he does is
constantly scene after scene show up and
save a [__] yeah it's Gonna Save
a [__] and then 10 minutes later
I gotta save a [__] like 10
minutes later yeah
I wondered that when I was a kid too
yeah because it's like you know why'd
you leave if you got the same
[__] why did you leave you know
why did you give him that key why don't
you just keep the key and then just give
it to him when you got there because you
know he could have lost the key right
this is all kinds of [__] crazy [__]
that you think about it's just but it
didn't seem to be that way when you're
reading the book because there's so much
other things right but when it's trimmed
down you realize that that's the formula
well and the thing about it too is that
in the formula in fantasy generally I
kind of feel like that's kind of the
rules where it's like stuff has to
happen in a particular order because
magic so I kind of feel like maybe this
so you can kind of give him some leeway
in that regard because you're sitting
there going I mean yeah because the
whole thing they find like after they
get you know captured by the trolls and
the trolls are gonna eat them and then
Gandalf is like shows up and is like
which uh it's like it's sunrise and so
like all the trolls are like oh [__]
then they all Turn to Stone and then
they go in the cave and they're like
woohoo like there's all this [__]
treasure in there yeah and then Gandalf
is like oh by the way um I have a map to
exactly where you're supposed to go
shoot right here like look check it out
there's the Secret Door did you go and
dad gave this to me and I had to give it
to me before and again I chose my own
time to give it to you
[__] I mean Thorin was a little bit
mad and it's like I understand I
understand that but he was just like
well um yeah why didn't my grandpa give
me this instead of just like giving it
to you maybe maybe the wizard stole it I
don't really know but yeah it did kind
of seem like
because I think I said when I was
watching this I was like the dwarves I
was like man can you guys walk 10 feet
without getting captured please that's
all it is they lost constantly and then
[__] they had to get saved
telling the story they had to pair it
all down oh
and so you definitely see the formula of
what Tolkien was doing yeah but you
didn't see that in the book because he
was read your reading right because
there are so many chapters that happened
you know
yeah so much happened in between in
between and there was a lot more content
yeah so it didn't quite you didn't quite
see the pattern that he had written into
there like yeah no they lose it every
turn but get off says you know what I
mean but it's just when you're telling
it in such a short period of time it's
just obvious
uh that Gandalf is a [__] doses ex
machina yeah and [__] everybody else
is just kind of yeah whatever they did
they weren't that important to the story
that's true but my favorite part and
like I said this even stood out to me as
a kid where they're like yeah we're
gonna go I think it was like toward the
end where it's like yeah we're gonna go
like do the rate we're gonna go up and
like to smogs mountain or whatever and
he's just and uh they're like well again
I was like yeah you have fun with that
and then they're like wait you're you're
not going and he's like nah I got I got
[__] to do you know what I mean and I
was just like seriously Gandalf come on
yeah why don't you just hang out again
why don't you tell them you'll meet him
there I mean you're a wizard it's like
if you had an appointment elsewhere you
could just like stop time there or some
[__] you know yeah
wherever they go why don't you just say
look man [__] go ahead and head up
there I'll see you when I when you all
get there yeah it's like this that's
what happens yeah because he can
apparently so he can just like move
around yeah so well and another thing
too and maybe this is addressed in the
book I don't know I haven't read it in a
long time so maybe somebody that's read
it more recently than me can like um can
tell me why this is and this is one
thing that kind of always confused me as
a kid too why in particular particular
did they choose Bilbo
like was it part was it some part of
some prophecy or something is that what
it was I'm gonna tell you what oh you
know why I know exactly why because I
was like why'd they just show up at this
random [__] he chose Bilbo
because Bilbo was totally unassuming and
harmless he's the every man okay okay
he's little
he has no experience in any of this [__]
he can't really even hurt anybody
so you as the reader when you're a young
boy okay do you really you can relate to
[__] bill and as he grows and gets
braver like exactly
no I I meant I mean I know that from
like a writer's standpoint I know why
they would choose him because like you
said he's in every man it's just like
it's the same kind of thing in all
fantasy it's Harry Potter it's all that
kind of stuff it's just like a regular
kid it's like just like you you know I
mean like the person right you just get
your home eating biscuits right yeah
smoking your pipe with your with your
little furry feet on your Ottoman and
you're only [__] for three feet at
all he's just like you
at least the furry feet is no I'm just
kidding I don't actually have furry feet
but I don't think little little boys
have three feet either well I guess it
would depend maybe some would but well
the thing about it is that I met in the
context of the story what was the
justification for them like choosing him
in particular like I know why they would
do it from a writer's standpoint that's
like for the meta standpoint I think I'm
saying in Universe why would they chose
him there's no reason because Ben said
there wasn't any particular prophecy it
was just Gandalf up to his tricks of
luring Hobbits away for Adventures yeah
so maybe that was just his kink
Gandalf he had a kink for it's just like
I just really really enjoy finding
random Hobbits and like throwing them
into these death-defying situations
that dude that played Gandalf in the
live action flick was an old gay dude
he's just old Queen who is yeah
McCulloch is he had this thing he had
these things for these little little
cutie twinks and [__] and he shows up
because we're going on an adventure me
and you put your shoes on
you got some cute ass feet
yeah
[Laughter]
that's what I meant I was like maybe
that's just Gandalf's kick he just like
it particularly think about something
good oh scones [__]
biscuits like my garden bacon yeah bacon
I think he said bacon and eggs you keep
thinking that yeah
keep thinking about making it yeah keep
thinking about that [__] who knows what
the hell's [__] Gandalf is doing in
the meantime that's what I mean and I
always kind of wondered too I always
wondered
I always wonder put your ankles behind
your ears I mean you know somewhere
because internet you know somewhere that
there's some Gandalf on Bilbo porn yeah
someplace then you know you're welcome
for putting that image in your head
because now I have it in my head too and
I'm the one who said it and I'm sorry so
you know what I mean but you know well
and because the same thing happens in
Lord of the Rings right it's just like
he cut
in the sense that I mean I guess that's
still kind of related because that's
Bilbo's
uh nephew right uh yeah no
Frodo is Bilbo's nephew yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's okay so I got it right I think
it's his Uncle Bill yeah yeah that's
what I thought yeah he was like it's
like I said it's been a while since I've
read the books or seen the movies Tom
Sykes says it definitely was weed that
Gandalf and Bill Burr were smoking oh
yeah yeah we they were taking mushrooms
they were doing [__] all kinds of
[__] I mean all kinds of stuff all kinds
they're doing [__] British [__]
British [__] psychedelics British
tribal psychedelics man yeah I mean
these are white people stories of course
it's gonna happen of course it's gonna
have [__] mushrooms and weeds white
people stories white people stories yeah
so let's talk about you know what one
thing that I had totally forgotten about
and you said you had forgotten about
this too because I thought
I don't know why I thought it ended like
after they got to smog's thing and yeah
I forgot about it does it but then after
that they do the whole Battle of the
Five Armies thing and I was like oh [__]
I forgot about that it's because they're
such [__] the the dwarves I mean they
could have [__] they didn't have they
didn't have to happen that didn't they
couldn't share the treasure I know with
people that deserve some [__] and
they had more treasure than they could
[__] out they could spend
and we're like yeah you got y'all could
have some smog was [__] y'all up
Smog he destroyed the whole yeah the
lake men's on the top of a [__] bill
but Bilbo was in there [__] around
burglarin okay like he made them think
that it was the the barrel riding well
he just didn't correct him yeah to be
fair still made him think he mentioned
yeah right so you're you're one of the
lake men and he just he could have just
said no no no no I'm not now he didn't
say that I'm just saying that like the
the dragon jumped to that conclusion
yeah but to be fair Bilbo did not
correct him on that although I think the
way they show it in the movie I think
that actually the dragon does go and he
would have destroyed the town but I
think he actually ends up destroying it
when he's dying yeah like because they
you know barred like shoots him in his
little little weak spot and then he
falls because remember I said oh it's a
tsunami because he like falls in the
water and there's fire and [__] like
that so I think that's what destroyed
the town not the dragon coming down
there and being like [__] you [__]
although that that's what would have
happened if you hadn't killed him now
there's another movie there's a very
similar story that I know influenced
this one uh that is almost even wider
than this [__] story all right and
that that is [__] Beowulf yeah the
the uh the one that the one that was CG
all CGI and it had uh again who was the
uh uh the dude the chick that played
Laura Croft
um Angelina Angelina General Lee was in
it
um the [__] crazy ass dude from
[__] Back to the Future
uh McFly McFly's dad what was his name
[__]
crazy crazy [__] um Chris
mclover Chris McLovin was in it he
played he played wait Crispin Glover
yeah Christopher Chris mclover was in it
he did he played uh
he played the monster
that was uh Grendel Grendel
Grendel and then later on the Dragon no
I forgot all about that we played Dremel
that movie didn't make much of an
impression yeah I liked that movie
although I love Beowulf I read it in
school and I loved it kind of similar to
this in in certain ways yeah and uh that
and and The Hobbit is kind of like a
reboot of those those kind of stories
it's an old Saxon story you know a bunch
of Geeks in it and [__] you know I mean
that's back in The Honky motherland
they're old yeah one of the first things
ever written in English and it's a very
old English I mean the only thing that
survives yeah yeah and it was written
down yeah that was back when English was
more like Icelandic and um that's a real
good story and the uh some of it was I
remember had to read it in high school
and it didn't yeah it makes sense but
then people analyzed it who are experts
of this story and they said shit's been
censored by the church this is probably
what the story originally was and they
restored it and made that movie and it
makes a lot more sense with the
restoration that
Beowulf has sex with Grendel's mother
yeah and that [__] Grendel's mother
the [__] witch could give birth to
dragons and if you were a bad
[__] she'd want to have your
baby to give to have a drag her just
thinking so that made a lot more sense
but they couldn't have that in the
Christian era where the king is having
sex with Beowulf's mom
to make a drag they ruin all the fun
stories right right that's probably what
it was everyone else real good voice
acting in it
it had [__] um Malkovich was in it
too John Malkovich John Malkovich was in
it remember he played Beowulf's uh or no
the uh Beowulf's right-hand man his
[__] Christian uh [__] um advisor
that was it was awesome Anthony Hopkins
was Anthony Hopkins I remember him being
in it by their voices but they did yeah
yeah yeah
Beowulf check it out people Ben said
none of the elves or lake men had done
anything much to help the dwarves who
were driven out by smog well now okay I
said they would fight them before though
okay I'll give you that for the elves
like the elves were kind of like being a
little graspy [__] but I don't I
don't know what happened prior to that
but I will say that the lakemen I was
under the understanding like when Thor
and oakenshield's grandfather was alive
like the dwarves and the um the lake men
had kind of been like simpatico you know
what I mean so I kind of feel like they
maybe had more of a claim to it than the
elves but like I said there might have
been some other because didn't like when
the elves first came and it was elves
the wood elves right yeah the wood there
are two different kinds of elves the
wood elves said they showed up said no
we we uh we're owed some of that
treasure because we've been fighting
that dragon and it did a lot of damage
to us over the years you know that's
basically what they said
and uh was like yeah okay all right
you're local it probably did [__] you
all over you could have some treasure
well and the dwarves are like oh hell no
we're not trash and the point that Bilbo
was trying to make it's just like
there's enough for everybody it's like
why are you dwarves hogging because you
don't you don't need all that you know
what I mean
and I think like it took Thorin because
he actually Dies at the End spoiler
alert I'm not among like I think it was
what seven other dwarves died in the in
the battle but you know he was kind of
like when he was dying he kind of like
apologized to Bilbo because he called
Bilbo a coward and I was like uh Bilbo
like saved y'all's bacon like throughout
the whole [__] movie like you guys
were just and I liked that Bilbo called
him out on that it's like yeah um who
was the one that went into the the
dragons Lair like well you guys just
[__] around out here me you know what
I mean who was it that like saved you
eyes from the spiders me so I was like
don't tell me don't call me a coward
[__] and saying I don't
understand war and all this other kind
of [__] so you know what I mean yeah
like I said I'm glad I'm glad he didn't
like get away with that they're in there
remembering the Beowulf movie and they
said yeah Malkovich was good into it he
had killed his mom for having sex with
his brother yeah there's all kinds of
[__]
[Music]
oh I remember was like oh I remember you
you're the one whose mom had sex with
your brother didn't you and you killed
them both for it yeah yeah yeah [__]
the best part about that one is [__]
the [__] Beowulf talks that's that's
really what the movie should be they
will talk
he talks big [__] yeah yeah he talks big
[__] but he backs it up
says yeah
he backs it up at every [__] court at
every turn the original superhero I
think that's what always kind of like
cracked me up about Beowulf is that like
cool because usually in real life like
if you're like a super badass and you
can do all this other stuff you just do
it and you don't like sit there and go I
can do this without anything else but
yeah but Beowulf is like is one of the
rare people that does both things like
he's actually like showing off about it
but he can't actually do it because
usually the more [__] you talk like the
less [__] you can actually do man they
[__] said I remember you Beowulf
you're the one that lost the swimming
match with listen he goes yes I'll tell
the story We swam for nine days
that's how he [__] started this
[__] we swam for nine days the Seas
were rough I was attacked by sea
monsters and the [__] he goes through
and he kills [__] 20 sea monsters and
does all kinds of [__] and he no he did
do that he was alive
yeah like I said usually people that are
exaggerated it's like oh my God I'm a
Navy SEAL and I went to space and like
all this other kind of [__] or just like
bullshitters
but it's like he's like that but they're
like no he actually did do that so yeah
and that's how he first came in contact
with the [__] mermaid that [__] him
over he saw that mermaid Beowulf's
weakness was [__] beautiful women and
it didn't have to be human
they just had to be beautiful he's like
whatever yeah boobies and like uh an
orifice he saw it he saw a beautiful
mermaid and that's really why he lost
the the race he got distracted yeah he
had to fight happens he just think it
was his penis and then the reason why
the dragon was killing everybody because
Grendel's mama was hot all right she was
Angelina Jolie
he couldn't help himself and then the
dragon [__] appeared out of it he
didn't mean to though
what are you gonna do that's what you do
but that's that is a [__] probably
what that story originally was kind of
knowing the psychology of of those days
that's probably what it was
so I agree with their restoration of the
story somebody mentioned that there was
a lot of Beowulf movies came around us
around the same time true I haven't seen
the other ones I can only attest to the
one I mean and that was the main one the
rest of them were kind of like not
knockoffs it's got Angelina Jolie in it
and [__] all-star cast see that one I
wouldn't mind seeing another adaptation
of that like that actually that would
probably be better as a series now that
I'm thinking about it because that's
like a very very complicated story yeah
um Ben Frey I'll talk about the lake men
they did Kill the Dragon to be fair yeah
I mean yeah Bilbo gave him the info to
kill the dragon and maybe they wouldn't
have done that otherwise but they're the
ones that did it like if they'd missed
with the era then they'd all be hosed
right so yeah they deserved some [__]
too honestly like everybody that came
there like I said there was really no
reason for the dwarves to be such
[__] about that [__] it caused this
whole battle they all got killed all
this other kind of [__] all these people
got killed just because there's like no
we just want all the gold you guys can't
have any Oracle says Bilbo only needed
enough money to keep him in eggs and
bacon and pipe weed for the rest of his
life yeah that was kind of like the
point was the Bilbo was what they he
took like two little bags of gold in his
little knife and he's like I don't
really need any more you know what I
mean yeah the real baby he was humble
the real big show has asked me if I
could sing like dangling
[Laughter]
[Music]
mode but no after about 20 minutes of
warming up yeah I could I can do Glenn
Danzig I could do a whole Glen dancing
album
yeah I'm saying all the [__] dancing
three How the Gods Kill I'll sing it
from the very beginning to the whole
thing yeah but call it Den glance yeah
call it [__] dead glance
how the cards deal
so they still kind of fix that yeah yeah
yeah see I love that idea I love it yeah
yeah
Ben says the wood elves claimed the
dwarves still owed them for some
business deals back before smog arrived
with some yeah see that's what I mean
it's like I kind of feel like everybody
that came there like hey you know like
you know give us some [__] money
[__] they probably had it all
had a good claim on that well because it
had been a while right how long do
dwarves live
do we know oh centuries
so the time the time of thorin's
Grandfather we don't know how long ago
that was I mean I'm sure they said but I
don't know
Tom Sykes says Reign of Fire is a great
Dragon film yeah I remember really
liking that actually I haven't seen in a
long time but I remember liking it Ben
says in Tolkien only men have ever been
able to slay dragons Okay see now I
didn't remember that little detail like
I said it's been a while I
I haven't read the books and since I was
probably in my late teens which was a
very long time ago and I haven't seen
the Peter Jackson movies
probably since they came out or like I
don't think I saw them in the theater
actually I think I saw them like a year
or two later like on cable so I don't
think I've seen them since then I
remember seeing the Hobbit trilogy
and not liking it so
I don't know I don't know if it's really
that much of a hot take to say that this
animated version is kind of like better
than I mean I guess it depends what you
mean by better I mean obviously the the
three movie
trilogy The Peter Jackson one is more
faithful to the book in the sense that
all of the book is in there and this one
you know leaves a lot it doesn't leave a
lot of the events out but it leaves like
out a lot of the context and the depth
and stuff just you know because it has
to be like short but I don't know I I
liked this one better than the movies I
know that's maybe weird to say but I
don't know
um let's see uh what I saw something
else oh after this I'm going to be
watching 1981's final exam gosh I
haven't seen that in a long time I
haven't seen that in a long time
and
dwarves live a few centuries yeah but
elves are Immortal for them it was like
last month
yeah okay
so yeah so I forgot too that there was
like two different kinds of elves that
was like you know the pretty elves with
like the shiny crowns and all that kind
of stuff and then there's like the wood
elves that sounded like out of breminger
that you know what I mean with the
little that were green and why not
one of the 80s slashers is getting a
sequel this year which one
because there were a lot
Bilbo's a simple man like the song yeah
yeah but like I said that was kind of
like the point of it I guess a small
chest of gold was worth a lot yeah I
mean he he could retire on it I'm not
saying that but he wasn't just like oh
my God I need like the whole [__] I
need all of it you know one thing they
don't mention is that you couldn't lift
a small chest of gold
this shit's heavy well he even said in
the cartoon because Gandalf said that's
all you took like was to that little
bags and he's like well that's all that
my pony could carry yeah and he's like
and that's all I'll ever need yeah so he
was just being practical gold is heavier
than lead yeah uh just a small box would
be I think we I think we mentioned that
when we were on the Mormon show when we
were talking about like the plates of
like the book of gold like I was like if
that book was actually made of gold it's
like I don't think you were carrying
that [__] anywhere a book the size of a
Bible made out of gold would probably be
about 20 30 pounds 40 pounds probably it
would be like that
uh Pat Hatfield said the mutilator is
the slasher I was trying to think of Tom
I've been wanting to do that on the show
actually because I think shutter added
it not too long ago and I haven't seen
that in a really long time either
and Bilbo didn't want another Pony to
carry more treasure yeah he was probably
just like [__] it this is enough for me
I'm fine
he just wants to go back to his little
hobbit hole and smoke his bite if you
know what I mean
Ben said bilba was already wealthy
was he really well he had enough to have
a nice house in a nice neighborhood so
yeah yeah I mean he looked like he was
having a he was happy with his life yeah
he just kind of chilled out and he
looked like he didn't have to work or
nothing so that's nice sit around eating
biscuits
bacon and eggs bacon eggs smoking we eat
it with his little furry feet yeah
like my little furry feet no all right
you're uh
I'm teasing I don't really have furry
feet no so you about ready to uh end
this one I reckon so okay all right so
tomorrow is haunting Mondays and the
episode that we're going to be doing is
another one from season seven I think
it's on that disc over there
um Child's Play remember I said I wanted
to do that one because the same guy that
was whose family was the subject of the
one we did last week yeah
um did a [__] like uh investigated this
other family's one that they made into
an episode two and he wrote a book about
it okay and it was free that's right we
have to do this one right so we were
gonna like do this I'm pretty sure it's
in the same scene what's it called again
Child's Play Just Like just like the
Chucky movie so we're gonna we're gonna
watch Child's Play on C on on [__] uh
haunting yeah what season is that I
think it's season seven it should be I
think it's on that same uh because the
season seven disc like box set is right
over there so if you guys want to watch
that tonight we're gonna watch it we're
going to review it tomorrow live yeah
and then on Tuesday we'll be talking
about the greasy Strangler from 2016
because we had a couple of requests to
do that and that's what won in the
patreon poll uh along with this one so
yeah so hopefully you guys have a good
rest of your weekend and we'll see you
guys again tomorrow talking about a
haunting good night